how to get your company to stand out in
a competitive market if you've got a
business you want customers to find you
you want them to talk about you you have
to stand out and be different and if you
can't do it through your product because
you're selling the same thing as
everybody else then you do it through
the service provide exceptional service
make people remember you make people
feel like they're welcome and they're
part of something give them an
experience so they're gonna go away from
working with your business telling their
friends you have to go work with these
guys I've got a question from one of my
newsletter readers Joseph who manages a
bank
he's a branch manager and he asked me
how do I get more people to come to my
branch instead of going to other banks
or other branches this is a great
question because as a bank you're
selling the same product right every
bank sells the same product you have the
same accounts same credit cards
everything is the same there's not a lot
of difference between the banks how
you're gonna stand out is through your
service so I want to tell you about two
banks that I've used here in Toronto and
wine hopefully you can learn from that
and for everybody else watching these
are nuggets that you can use and apply
to your business okay the first is TV so
I do most of my banking at TD a lot of
the reason is because of this one branch
that opened up next to my location this
was a test branch for them and they give
you an experience okay when you walk
into that branch you feel special it was
a test pilot for them and basically
everyone is like a Walmart greeter there
you come in they welcome you you feel
accepted they remember your name they
ask you how you're doing and you feel
like they care about you even if it's a
little bit for sometimes you feel like
they care about you okay if there's any
kind of line up the manager gets up from
her chair and she comes to the front to
start making that line up move faster
who does that the manager often is just
sitting there at the back doing doing
their work he or she comes to the front
because she doesn't want people standing
in line
okay they look for ways to help me I
have eight or nine different accounts
with with TD and I went in recently in
one of the guys who was at the front
tells me hey this one account that you
have you're not doing as many
transactions to it as you were before
you can actually downgrade it and save
some money on it who does that who tells
you to do that right what bank would
tell you to do that here's a way to
spend less money with us right Thanks
don't do that
but this branch does and that's why I
love these guys because I'm gonna send
them more accounts and way more business
and I leave one to tell everybody about
this branch when my friends tell me and
they complain about the banks that
they're working with say you know what
you got to go work with these guys go
check them out and they're worth
switching banks for you have people who
have been lifelong clients with a
certain bank this is worth switching
over because they get much better
service so provide great service okay
there's one other branch so I had that
my mortgage with Bank of Montreal and
the one thing I loved about this Bank of
Montreal branch is when you walked in
they were coffee and cookies so if
you're standing in line yeah I don't the
stand in line at TD but thank you
Montreal there's a line you can grab a
coffee and get some cookies I know it's
just a nice touch so they're finding
their own way even though I have to
stand in line they make that experience
a little more enjoyable so whatever your
your product is if you can't stand out
with your product stand out with your
service make it enjoyable to work with
you give people a reason to talk about
you your customers they run busy lives
okay we all have busy lives we all have
a million things going on so for you to
stand out and for them to want to talk
about you being good isn't enough if
you're just good with your service then
they're not going to slam you they're
not going to tell their friends are what
a crappy company this is you have to be
great you have to
you've got to stand out with something
go so over-the-top over-deliver like
crazy so that they can't wait to go tell
their friends oh my god you got to go
work at this branch you got to take your
business here because that's what I do
with my TV branch now TV itself
I like their website I like this one
branch some of the other branches suck
you got to get to work TV you got to fix
those branches but I love the branch
next to my office and that's where I do
my banking and I tell all my friends to
go so provide great service so customers
will want to talk about you believe for
those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
always makes trying to do more for you
and leave a comment let me know what you
think you have a question I'll make a
video response for you subscribe to the
channel if you like this video thank you
guys so much and I'll see you soon